et pour francesco risotto de la faculté
de droit de l'université est liverpool
hope est cette affaire est bien plus
qu'une histoire d'argent écoutez
[Musique]
je pense qu'ils auraient vraiment commis
dans cette affaire
pourquoi y aurait-il besoin de plusieurs
semaines pourrait soutenir les français
dans la lutte dans la reprise de
contrôle des frontières britanniques ce
qui était le sujet du président
cela lui fait de cadeau il ya un
contrôle des frontières que tu es tu
de problème
lorsque le royaume uni faisait partie de
l'union européenne à des traités tels en
place pour gérer le problème avec le prg
exciter les règles de l'union ne
s'applique plus match manche de wii
party où ça joue bien davantage que plus
de politique de un sentiment de méfiance
que d'affaires de financement de 60
quelques millions d'euros c'est un
symptôme d'une crise profonde entre les
deux pays